alors que ces dernières semaines tous
les événements regroupant du public ont
été annulés en france en raison de
l'épidémie avec le déconfinement
plusieurs questions se posent quant à la
fête de la musique qui va se dérouler
dans un peu plus d'un mois en france
pourra-t-on jouer de la guitare dans les
rues sera-t-il possible de se réunir sur
les places des villes et villages pour
assister à des concerts rien n'est moins
sûr mais en attendant de savoir quelles
seront les mesures décidées par le
gouvernement en fonction de la situation
en juin les équipes de france 2 ont déjà
pris de l'avancé
alors que chaque année une émission est
consacrée pour célébrer la musique en
direct
elle avait accueilli dans le passé à
nice plus de 30000 spectateurs une
configuration inimaginable aujourd'hui
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
producteurs du show ont décidé de
maintenir l'émission mais sans public
c'est pourtant à l'accord hôtel arena de
paris que le tournage se déroulera mais
dans une salle totalement vide
intitulé tous ensemble pour la musique
cette émission recevra les artistes du
moment et diffusera aussi des séquences
souvenir pour célébrer la musique
une initiative qui explique alexandra
rey damiel directrice des
divertissements de france télévisions
l'idée est de rassembler une trentaine
d'artistes afin d'organiser une soirée
en soutien aux salles qui ne peuvent pas
ouvrir pour le moment et les festivals
qui sont annulés cet été reste à savoir
si son public l'ambiance de cette fête
populaire aura quand même de la saveur
alors la fête de la musique aura bien
lieu sur france 2 mais dans une salle
vide
bonne ou mauvaise idée
je pense que la directrice des
divertissements de france 2 va être
contente de la voix qu'on lui a faites
aussi alexandra rey d'alten copine voilà
vous savez que j'aime bien mais alors et
je vais vous dire tout c'est vraiment
une copie d'un mois mais ça ne m'empêche
pas l'appeler 4 5 fois par jour pour
lire qu elle dit des conneries
voilà mais j'aime bien mais le sait je
lui dis voilà sa famille c'est l'amitié
on est là messieurs l'adorent c'est une
personne et qui a pris beaucoup de
risques sur france 2 franchement on va
dire la vérité elle tombe plein de
choses
j'aime bien parce qu'elle bouge voilà
mais après c'est normal voilà là pour
moi ça c'est n'importe quoi mais
vraiment je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais moi je suis dubitative
vraiment je m'interroge parce que la
musique c'est justement la chaleur c'est
les gens qui applaudissent et dans l'âme
surtout la fête de la musique il ya dix
ans je suis la reine de nîmes c'est la
fausse c'est ce 6
enfin voilà il ya une sorte de ferveur
la sphère faire décider les groupes les
uns après les autres sur un plateau qui
va qui somme toute ce sera assez froid
je sais pas comment je vais aux
spectateurs vont le recevoir ce temps
pense que notre public j'ai envie
d'avoir la vie du bourg gicquel j'assume
je suis comme un valérie benaïm était
dubitatif ouais ben moi je suis parti
très envie d'écouter de la musique on
al'envie devoir d'aider nouvelles choses
mais et son public la fête de la musique
c'est une fête à laquelle appellent lara
sera de la musique oui et puis pardon le
débarquement c'est la date du
débarquement de la fête de la musique
c'est le 21 juin donc dire on prend le
symbole il faut le faire parce que c'est
un symbole mais sur une feinte de
symboles ont fait la date du symbole
bien su alors c'est pas parce que il
c'est vrai un problème technique chez
plutôt content donc si on le fait deux
jours avant ça rime encore moins à rien
nous on vous emmerdez pas et que c'est
un oui raymond noms mais jorge ans j'ai
envie d'y croire parce que ça me fait
peur si le 19 juin dans 20 dans trente
jours si le 19 juin on peut toujours pas
faire la fête de la musique s'est passé
ça veut dire qu'on aura pas ouvert les
bars on n'en a rien fait ça me fait
flipper j'ai envie d'avoir espoir qu'ils
ont pris une décision trop tôt et que le
19 juin
non mais on pourra pas être imposée j'ai
envie d'avoir juste c'est ma vie mon
chéri sur est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ou pas parce que là tu restes tu
sais que je t'aime je pense y aller moi
ce genre ce jour j'ai envie que le 19 ce
soit fini que oui mais j'entends qu'un
match se fera certainement une interview
pour télé star du monde on peut voir que
c'est une bonne idée
bien sûr que je suis comme les camarades
bien sûr que c'est pas une bonne idée de
faire la fête de la musique tout seul
comme ça à limiteront passe un best-of
où on a fait la fête de la musique mon
sa boîte et avec des belles images mais
là cela fait de la musique il faut
chanter faux créé et si le 19 juin on
est encore dans cette galère wahou
alors le jean michaut moussala
absolument aucun sens et les milices et
vont jouer pour la fac ils auront fini
dernière note
n'a pas d'applaudissements il a rien du
tout mal joué c'est que j'imagine mais
il joue au théâtre où personne n'a
précisé que le truc comme ça s'est passé
au cap est il son capot diffuser ses
stars c'est la fête des amis et c'est
une décision rapide pour huit voix que
le 19 juin tara pas la fête de la
musique mais tu es quand même dans le
métro toi c'est quand même un truc temps
ça c'est vrai mais ça n'hésite pas à le
dire dans son interview